[Music]
hello welcome to Week in Review I'm Adam
Bolton Kevin Maguire and Andrew Pierce
are here with me to look back at the
biggest stories of the past seven days
so Kevin what was your top story I think
it's gotta be the continuing saga that
is that lying racist Trump a gift that
keeps on givin salutely and yours
historic moment at last we're on the way
the brexit vote was a big vote for
brexit and article 50 being triggered at
last and that is indeed our top story
this week we finally got to see the plan
for the UK's exit from the European
Union MPs have voted overwhelmingly to
trigger the start of the process after
two days of impassioned debate our
political editor Faisal Islam reports
Austin in Lincolnshire the most
Euroskeptic place in the UK seventy-five
percent voted leave policy in relation
to the EU
MPs from the Commons brexit committee
are on the road here trying to
understand what the public really wants
from brexit in the Commons finally David
Davis delivered the white paper on his
brexit strategy our best days are still
to come
delivering a smooth mutually beneficial
exit avoiding a disruptive cliff edge
will be the key but too little too late
said the opposition this statement says
nothing the sector state now makes a
statement saying there'll be a white
paper but the white paper has not been
delivered until a few minutes ago so
that we can meaningfully actually ask
him questions about it it is 77 pages
and expands a bit on the prime
minister's speech last month some
elements seemed a little rushed
including an erroneous chart suggesting
Britons enjoyed three months holiday a
year the key promises that pledge that
we will take control of our own affairs
meaning an end to the role of the
European Court of Justice but it could
be replaced by other dispute resolution
mechanisms controlling immigration is
key for the government but it says there
may be a phased process of
implementation including new laws
although membership of the single
markets ruled out we're told to resume
will prioritize securing the freest and
most frictionless trade possible but
in the UK and the EU back in Boston how
immigration is controlled is the big
unknown unilaterally guaranteeing the
rights of EU nationals in Britain could
yet be the flashpoint in the Commons
next week
well Kevin I mean what interests me is
everyone saying ice array we're on the
way out as a appears to say but it's not
as far as I was saying this has still
got to get through Parliament absolutely
and if it takes you eight months to come
up with a 77 page white paper riddled
with errors let's try and say you wrap
up negotiations in two years to
disentangle Britain from 44 years of
cooperation you're right I think the big
votes are next week when MPs will
attempt to guide the negotiations
important issues on will MPs get a vote
before the final deal is accepted will
she have to report back Tereza mayor
regularly will they see impact studies
on what for jobs earnings security
prosperity every move she makes would
have a bigger label rebellion next week
you think I would have thought so 47 on
the initial vote I think will be bigger
and there's gonna be more resignations
if Jeremy Corbyn has the strength to
sack people who will not go along did
the refere at the revolt was bigger
because there were quite a lot of
abstentions - I think we were up to
about 60 which is a huge rebellion
really when you think it's a three-line
width and for years it was the
Conservative Party it has been deviled
by damaging division on Europe one Tory
voted against Ken Clark who's who's
likely a grandiy and enriches your euro
file and even people like Anna Sabri
came on side because they know the
damage potentially for them at the
ballot box but I think we're going to
see more trouble next week but I do
think that vote the scale of the victory
for the government sends an important
signal to the House of Lords where there
could be potentially real trouble but I
wouldn't ignore the Tory divisions which
I think will become apparent as once you
get into the the details every scale of
the labor know it's true labour Labour's
got neighbours got the big problem at
Teddy's Tory Prime Minister takes you it
takes us in Europe then it just
thatcher major certainly cameron Mae is
not out of the woods on this yet but we
are on the way out we are about time too
unless there's a second referendum they
won't be long good luck good luck but
also by the next general election we
won't be fully out because it's far more
complex and you pretended it yeah we're
gonna be a second referee in your dream
well this is not gonna be the last week
that Europe is our top story but in a
busy week of news here are five things
that you might have missed all perhaps
even forgotten already
six people were murdered in an attack on
a mosque in Canada a student Alexandre
Bissonnette was charged with carrying
out the killings during evening prayers
he reportedly had nationalist and
right-wing sympathies it was revealed
that a chef who traveled to Syria to
join the Kurds in their fight against
the Islamic state killed himself to
avoid capture Ryan Locke is reported to
have died in December during the
offensive to retake the city of Raqqa
from is the 20 year old who had no
military experience joined the militia
last August after telling his family he
was going on a holiday to Turkey the
sister of the murdered MP Joe Cox
launched the project Cox was working on
before her death a commission on
loneliness friends and colleagues will
work alongside 13 organizations and
charities to help those who feel
isolated million people took to the
streets in Romania to protest about
changes to corruption laws the
government wants to free or reduce the
sentences of officials who've been
jailed for corruption and removed the
offense of criminal negligence and now
for our gaffe of the week
imagine training for a half marathon
enduring the physical and mental
challenge of completing the course only
to have your time struck from the record
books well that's what happened to the
32,000 people who took part in last
year's great Scottish run it turns out
those responsible for measuring the
course came up short
150 metres short in fact
event organizers have apologized to the
participants and gentlemen I mean you
must be gutted your records been
one-and-a-half merit
I used to face to run half-marathons the
Great North Run yeah Callum Hawkins who
won this one why hour and 20 odd seconds
it must be gut-wrenching for him
absolutely gut-wrenching and don't
forget you can send us your nominations
using the hashtag W in our well this
week train commuters also had something
to smile about
after rail firms launched a trial scheme
to simplify ticketing it's aimed to make
the cheapest option the easiest option
for passengers scars adele Robinson
explains
[Music]
Andy Brown uses trains in the south most
weeks like others he's confused by what
deals are best I often travel where I am
will go away for a few days so getting a
return to pick that covers span of time
and getting the right one possible of
course he's not alone it's easy enough
to use the machines but whether you're
getting the best but the best cost for
your route is it's something the rail
industry itself recognizes train
companies and Network Rail have come up
with a pilot action plan to overhaul
ticket pricing offering best
and eliminating the need for which may
help somewhat mitigate the extreme
lengths some have had to go to to get
the best value this Newcastle supporter
bought 56 tickets for two people to go
to Oxford and back saving 60 pounds
train companies will pilot the reforms
on selected routes a step in the right
direction but in the midst of rising
ticket prices passengers say they want
much much more where seems to me even if
you buy one ticket you get about three
bits of paper after that out of the
machine now how did this 56 tickets work
the two of them are travelling from
Newcastle to Oxford in Newcastle lost
actually three no but they you you went
on you got your tickets for the stations
in between instead of getting a single
ticket all the way from Newcastle to
Oxford you might have gone the Durham
then Darlington and so on total nonsense
but the whole system is these
profit-hungry real companies are out to
make as much money from you as they can
I'm glad the government starting to
force them but this happens time after
time I thought the idea was you know you
paid according to how many miles you
travel yeah it should be if you buy your
ticket from a machine and don't forget a
lot of ticket offices have been closed
down because we're in an automated era
it the cheapest ticket for the time
should come up but it doesn't it is
absolutely baffling I met I know I'm
only have limited intelligence but I
stopped with machines people here from
abroad we've got record numbers of
foreign people here it is confusing my
worry is though if we do then start to
get the cheapest tickets because they
are enforced to simplify how will they
get the revenue bet they'll put the
fares up even more others they are the
biggest ripoffs in commercial business
you'll finally got a pretty fat profit
The Fat Controller should say a small
bit of good news for southern rail users
that one of the union's only one atom
only it's got to be accepted by the
drivers themselves but the union has
left has recommended it the guards
dispute is still ongoing we're not sure
the details but no it's good it's
settled but drivers had and I'm sure God
do also legitimate safety concern except
that they say
parent company runs trains on a
different company on the same route
without conductors without any problem
at all and just when that's all you want
to get results just when it's just
beginning to get resolved the tubes are
on strike for three days next week now
are you sitting comfortably quiz of the
week can you tell me what's or how
what's on your feet could affect your
brain no oh I think I might know yeah
you answers after the break welcome back
to week in review i'm adam bolton and
joining me are Kevin Maguire associate
editor of The Daily Mirror and Andrew
pierce consultant editor of The Daily
Mail well before the break we asked you
can you tell me why what's on your feet
could affect your brain and you've
obviously got the right thing so me sir
me son I know so how's the outside he
doesn't know sir he doesn't know it is
slippers there was a school experiment
by allowing pupils to wear slippers
instead of shoes it was great what if
you put slippers on your feet you just
relax more you will you will study
better um it's kind of counterintuitive
isn't it you think right you go away
uniform you your shoes dress for school
gate you thought was pretty fat it seems
to be working do you own slippers
because I'm afraid I don't I do alright
week two of Donald Trump's presidency
and no sign of the new man in the White
House slowing down or changing his
approach his travel ban on people from
seven predominately Muslim countries saw
thousands of people protests in the
streets and at airports mr. Trump then
turned his attention to international
diplomacy with rather mixed results as
US correspondent Greg Milam reports Rex
Tillerson is the man Donald Trump chose
to serve as America's chief diplomat he
can hardly have expected that within
hours of this swearing-in he'd be facing
the most extraordinary diplomatic route
with one of his country's
closest allies this weekend phone call
between Trump and Australian Prime
Minister Malcolm Turnbull it turns out
didn't go well
it's reported Trump cut the calls short
during a discussion over a deal to
resettle mostly Muslim refugees rejected
by Australia in the u.s. Trump tweeted
do you believe it the Obama
administration agreed to take thousands
of illegal immigrants from Australia why
I will study this dumb deal comes with
the Trump administration already facing
its first serious foreign policy test it
says Iran's decision to carry out more
of this test firing ballistic missiles
breaches UN resolutions if not the
nuclear deal that trump has consistently
criticized Trump's new national security
advisor delivered this warning president
Trump has severely criticized the
various agreements reached between Iran
and the Obama administration as well as
the United Nations as being weak and
ineffective instead of being thankful to
the United States in these agreements
Iran is now feeling emboldened as of
today we are officially putting Iran on
notice thank you on notice of what the
White House wouldn't say nor whether
military action was on or off the table
it has been reported that in a phone
call last week Trump threatened the
Mexican president with sending US troops
to deal with what he called bad hombres
it wasn't the White House said a threat
to invade Mexico say Andrew I mean
anything wrong really with telling other
world leaders what you really think well
he's just gonna do it in a different way
isn't it that's the point
it's called megaphone diplomacy we've
heard that expression but literally with
Donald Trump that's what he does you'd
have thought you'd have wanted to have a
better relationship with the Prime
Minister of Australia it's a traditional
ally of the United States and to
alienate him shouting at him swearing at
him and then cut off the gall and then
to brag about it
he seems extraordinary come on he's a
prize idiot Trump Bernie you need skills
in this job he misrepresents everything
it was going to be a people swap with
Australia and you've got the ridiculous
position out but justify his racist
travel ban you have his aid in the white
house
Kellyanne Conway inventing a massacre by
Islamist in the state the bawling green
mask it never happened exist it's pure
fantasy this is utterly crazy the ban is
what he said he would do in his in the
presidential campaign he's caring except
he did say in the campaign he said he
wanted a ban on Muslims yes he now says
this isn't a Muslim kisses is it's a
predominantly McVeigh offered on the
Muslims country but also the list of
course who got from Obama and people say
why not say I have no intention of
banning people from that for list this
is it look do not try to defend the
indefensible you will get into a swamp
it'll you in Donald Trump Donald
Trump's policy is proving very popular
in the United States with polls have
given him a massive lead or this he
knows exactly what he's doing Kevin chat
says he's an idiot he's not an idiot he
wouldn't be an idiot he's got to become
president United States by being very
very clever
well my line this policy is popular rat
poison so why didn't need to bring in
the band with Saudi Arabia whole Kevin
says he's got business interests there's
intelligence share between United States
and Saudi Arabia which is why I didn't
do sad you're a business interest now on
to your choices of top newspaper stories
of the week and really archbishop of
yeah Justin Welby put on the spot
because this investigation into the
summer camps that took place in the late
70s and 1980s it was a ostensibly a
church summer camp he was working as a
volunteer at this camp where the guy who
ran it John Smith is a QC now South
Africa was subjecting boys teenage boys
to severe beatings he was making them
strip naked and beating them with a cane
with a cane and and it was their
punishment and it was and and there was
a sexual undertone it suggested to what
he was doing he's in South Africa says
he's done nothing wrong
Winchester school has been dragged into
this because some of the pupils went to
these camps and the school was aware of
the abuse and it is a form of abuse and
it never got referred to the police it
was covered under the archbishop has
apologized he has apologized and he said
the church should have done more the
school should have done whether he knew
what was going on that he says he knew
nothing about it he said even heard a
whisper it's embarrassing for him but
there was an era when the BBC quest
questions over Stuart Hall and Jimmy
Savile absolute mothering we know it
because I mean some of the people who
were being caned with 21 I mean there
yeah yeah no but it's it's still
exploitation it's still abuse and then
people were being prideful yeah Kevin
your story
it's a ban on CBS at Ernst & Young one
of the big accountancy companies and
they found if you look at a CV you begin
to favor certain people so they've gone
blind and they're more working-class
kids are getting recruited nonce non
private school kids and they're
beginning to rape them on ability with
tests rolling looking at which school
they went to in their backgrounds even
if you have a work experience because
well-connected people can get their kids
in and they're finding they're getting
better accountants it should be more
widespread because there is a problem
that a small group in society is hogging
the jobs and a lot of very talented kids
are being locked out yeah as one who
went to a state school combination so I
think it's great but you see why they've
you see these in the past because it's a
quick filter yeah no I would have
thought inefficient I used to be a big
supporter of using CBS I'm not too sure
now after this you know the proof is
there in the recruits instant young when
they have hi to you you wasting your
life being a motorist no according to
this research now motorists are spending
four days a year
not raging at but traffic jams which is
probably 14 days a year trying to park a
car it the average motorist in London
it's eight minutes because there are not
enough spaces and and if it was me when
I find the space it'd be another eight
minutes trying to park the car because
I'm no good apart I'm a little
suspicious of the the time here but I am
relieved that you don't drive I do try I
just don't have a car keep it that way
there's enough danger on the road
disease that's the weekly shopping his
car
I do well I'd rather take depart right
another set another story you may have
feeling I've heard before the actor
played doctor who is retiring he has
Peter Capaldi and the thirteenth doctor
we'll we'll find one in in December
could be a woman could regenerate as a
woman Olivia Colman
it was a funtastic actor don't know
superb in brought the broadchurch 2012
why not less she want it after more than
50 well it's my weather - you could
easily have a woman mystic I have
noticed apparently not that I watch
Doctor Who but I do follow these things
that all Doctor Who's sidekicks are
currently men yes logical yeah and she's
a terrific actress and we love her and
broadchurch is back in the next few
weeks and she is fantastic I've got to
say I'm glad Peter assigned women you
mean I'm just thinking the psychics are
usually women Peter Capaldi who stood
down is Tennant was useless he was he
wasn't it wasn't as good as Matt Smith
or David touched the freckles from David
Tennant he he was probably wasn't as bad
as Peter David Icke John Pertwee was my
favorite is your face it's great it's
shown your rage I think it was
Christopher Eccleston look at the weekly
newspapers what about the thumbs-up and
thumbs-down of the week the ups and
downs Andrew this is this rapper called
Drake who of course I've never heard of
but he's offered a refund to people who
went to his gig after one of his fellow
performers fell through a hole in the
stage which is remarkable and I think we
can see look just watch this very
laughs what does so he goes this is a
wrap yes actually a doubt yeah but it's
a really foregone tab but we think is
that because he's offered a refund and
the performer was hurt too badly we know
he's alright yeah it's great to see that
yes hopefully before were actually said
he quite enjoyed it I think you did but
I understand what it did with it stopped
some special effects working oh is that
right which is why the money wasn't want
to go see a rapper anyway
alright Northern Lights now these are
these fantastic dazzling rays of solar
arrays that we see sometimes because of
changes in solar energy powers which I
don't understand because it's part of
two had to go for me
and we may not see them over Britain
anymore and they will be restricted to
the North Pole oh no no it's to do with
it is to do with wind and movements of
solar energy
apparently I think some changes our
natural weak cause others are a global
warming climate changes the man-made it
is real I think I think this is just you
know over time it's right I cannae was
at the 16th century or the great doesn't
like a mini ice age and the Thames would
freeze her yeah I use frozen at the
moment yeah have either of you ever seen
the Northern Lights
no no suddenly not we better get in that
quick exactly and there Kevin your
choice is then up let go it is now
considered the most powerful brand in
the world overtaking Disney and I just
love the fact that these little colorful
blocks you build you know I did it as a
kid I've done it with my own kids it's
still an it's rather symbol and in an
age when computer games although they
have store on this square in London and
they run up to Christmas they'd have to
have bounces outside to police the
queues and people would only be allowed
to go in for about 20 minutes of time
because it was such a stampede I hated
Lego as a child loathed bricks to build
what you wanted but there's also a Lego
Batman movie which is there is branding
gone man yeah it's not it's not very
well
what does Legoland down and wins or the
theme parks are available you know
they're very clever with their marketing
right hand down oh it's got to be Johnny
Depp and he's spending he's suing these
business managers but they say hang on
you be a control $30,000 a month and
wine they say he spent three million
dollars on a cannon to send hunter s
Thompson ears ashes into the air
he doesn't just buy an island in the
Caribbean buys Ireland's doesn't buy a
house in France hi guys I do you think
that is the $30,000 I think he's paid a
bit more per bottle than you does not
the fire you get I think it's probably a
vintage do you still get your three for
ten in a stir yeah
other supermarkets are available I'm
glad I never get invited
so it's Johnny Depp yeah he's gay dad
well thank you very much indeed and
please don't forget you can send us your
nominations you just have to use the
hashtag W in our well thanks very much
indeed for joining us for our review of
the week we will be back next week for
now it's goodbye from them goodbye and
goodbye from me goodbye
[Music]